local mother accused of killing her two
children appeared in court this morning
clark county prosecutors say 26 year old
amanda sharp jefferson drowned her
victims
and then denied knowing them bianca
holman is following the case
amanda sharp jefferson is facing two
counts of murder in the death of her
one-year-old
rose singleton and her two-month-old
lily singleton
according to an arrest report jefferson
told the children's father
she drowned them both girls were
discovered by their father jaquan
singleton
singleton told police she was acting
strange a few weeks earlier but seemed
fine when he saw her the evening prior
police say sharp jefferson denied having
any children and said someone must have
put them
in her apartment at first sharp
jefferson was not in the courtroom
her lawyer claimed that there was
concerns about the reaction to the
allegations
she eventually appeared and said she
understood the charges
and also understood the next date for
her scheduled preliminary hearing
i do not find that the
concerns expressed at least at this
juncture
would outraid the public's right to at
least
view electronically the arraignment
sharp jefferson's lawyer also filed two
motions the first is to preserve
evidence the second regarding bail sharp
jefferson will return to court on
november
24th reporting from the regional justice
center bianca holman 8 news now